Michael I've learned you since you were
a child
neva gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease you'll find it
[Music]
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this
I have a rare blood disease and I'm not
that at a time video
this could be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly label
I don't want to see you get hurt more
than you already have this would be a
cure
at what cost
[Music]
I went from time
[Music]
increased strength is speed
the ability is echolocation
and then overpowering nerds to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing old
good guy anger what's up guy
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have our first official teaser
trailer for Morbius as you just saw it's
a very long teaser trailer and it's
packed with a ton of information about
how Jared Leto's character Michael
Morbius becomes Morbius the living
vampire and of course there's also many
different MCU references as well
particularly involving spider-man which
makes sense because spider-man and
Morbius have a long history in the
comics so we're gonna break down
everything you need to know about this
trailer I'm still doing the Xbox one and
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is subscribe with notifications turned
on like the video and leave a comment
about the trailer down below I'm picking
a winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so the trailer
starts off with a character saying
Michael I've known you since you were a
child you have a gift
you always have now Jared Leto's
character of course is dr. Michael
Morbius and as they mentioned in the
trailer he has a rare blood condition
however that is not the gift that he is
talking about the gift is that he's
actually a genius the first scene is
most likely taking place in Greece when
we see him as a kid because he grows up
in Greece before going to New York as an
adult and in this one scene we see him
limping down an aisle people are
clapping for him and then when he gets
to the podium we can see behind him and
says Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine dr. Michael Morbius
so he's incredibly smart smart enough to
have won a Nobel Prize and he spends his
life trying to find a cure to his rare
blood condition as the trailer goes on
we finally hear him talk and he says I
should have died a long time ago why am
I here if not to fix this we see him in
the hospital
attending to sick kids we can see that
he's a good person but then he says I'm
running out of time and then we see him
pull out a vampire bat and then he says
this could be my last chance we hear the
female doctor in this scene say you're
up to something what is it now this
doctor is Martine Bancroft and in the
comics she is the fiance of Michael
Morbius it's unclear if she's going to
be his romantic interest or fiancee in
this but she's definitely in this as
another doctor trying to help him find a
cure but she says I don't want you to
get hurt more than you already have so
there's clearly some more interest in
there besides a professional
relationship but then he says that he's
found a cure but it's not
actly legal and then they cut to a scene
of him in a cave with a bunch of vampire
bats now we can see that he's kind of
surrounded by walls kind of these
strings falling down most likely some
sort of a cage for him that's most
likely electrotherapy he cuts his hand
in the beginning of the cave and he
allows the vampire bats to come and get
his blood now the reason that this is
most likely some sort of a cage for
electrotherapy is because that's how he
gets his powers in the comics and the
comics when he is trying to cure himself
of his blood disease he does it with an
experimental treatment involving vampire
bat DNA and electroshock therapy but of
course this did not cure his condition
instead it gave him a new condition it
gave him sway dough vampirism which
means he needs to ingest blood in order
to survive and that's when we cut back
to Martine in the trailer and she says
at what cost then she is replying to him
saying this could be a cure but not
exactly legal and of course the cost is
that he's turning into a vampire and
then we see this happen he's stuck in
the cage and we can see that he's
clearly changing he's starting to feel
the effects of the experiment that he
just did and he starts punching the
walls and he starts actually breaking
them because this is one of his powers
after the experiment he gets superhuman
strength and then he finally starts
changing and he starts to do other
experiments about what condition he may
now have we see him in this chamber with
all the bats it seems like he's kind of
controlling them and the blood disease
that he had was a disease that made his
body decay eventually the blood
condition would consume his body and he
would eventually die and that's what he
says in the trailer he says I went from
dying to feeling more alive than ever
and we see him on the table his body
decaying but then we see him come out
and he looks like a completely changed
man and then from here he actually does
a rundown of all of the powers that he
now has he says I have increased
strength and speed we see him lifting up
a tomb that no man should really ever be
able to lift up because they are just
super heavy we see him catch an apple
that was thrown at him with his eyes
closed
so his reflexes are also unplanned then
when he's talking about speed we can see
him running through this hall light he's
not just running on the floor he's
running on the walls he's running on the
roof and it may look like he has the
ability to teleport but in the comics he
doesn't have this ability he's just
extremely fast and the trailer it kind
of looks like Nightcrawler from the
x-men it kind of looks like he's
vanishing here and there but it's
actually him just moving
and insanely fast speeds they've just
done a really good job on the effects of
him running I actually really like this
and then he says he has the ability to
use echolocation now this is an ability
that bats have in real life you may have
heard people say blind as a bat well
bats aren't exactly blind however they
see mostly using echolocation and this
is essentially the same as submarines
using sonar essentially what happens is
they put out a noise a sound some type
of vibration and that basically maps out
their surroundings around them and you
can see him do that in this trailer he
puts out a sound and he can see all of
the vibrations of everything around him
so this helps him see in the dark
because when he gets this new vampiric
condition he actually is advert to the
light as well just like you've heard an
old vampire stories vampires can't be in
the light it's the same thing with
Morbius he really doesn't like the light
and hurts him as well and then of course
we hear him say the last ability and an
overpowering urge to consume blood and
then we see him use all of these
abilities to take out some sort of SWAT
team that's coming at him turning into a
true vampire and then we have just a ton
of Easter eggs we hear Morbius say how
far are we allowed to go to fix
something that is broken and as he says
this we see him walking down an alley in
what looks like prison clothes but the
main thing about the scene as you can
see spider-man on the wall right behind
him and ona it says wanted this confirms
that this movie does in fact take place
in the same time in the same universe as
spider-man far from home because the
last time we left spider-man and far
from home he was wanted for killing
Mysterio and I'll talk about this more
in just a bit
we then seized Simon Stroud who was
Tyrese Gibson the character and he's a
person that in the comics was a former
CIA agent which is what we see him here
in this movie but later goes on in the
comics to hunt Morbius and man-wolf
and then we see luck seus crown or
hunger a hunger is most likely the main
antagonist of the movie because in the
comics he is a spider-man villain and a
Morbius villain and although it's
unclear of what his actual role in the
movie will be he is most likely the main
villain and then we go back to Morbius
saying how far are we allowed to go to
fix something that is broken and it
shows him actually drinking the blood of
some people that he's killed and then we
hear the doctor say
until the remedy is worse than the
disease and then we see somebody running
down the hallway the lights are
flickering on and off
person is clearly scared and then
Morbius attacks and then we finally see
dr. Michael Morbius as a vampire the
remedy is no longer the cure he's
completely turned into a vampire who
needs blood in order to survive but at
the final parts of the trailer we hear a
voice and it says Michael Morbius
you've got tired of doing the whole good
guy thing huh and then it's revealed
that the person that is saying this is
vulture the same exact vulture Adrian
from spider-man
homecoming and this officially confirms
that Morbius does take place inside of
the same universe that Spiderman takes
place in which of course is the MCU we
have an actual character from spider-man
homecoming that was in the MCU in
Morbius and Sony's spider-verse
not to mention the picture of spider-man
on the wall which by the way is from
spider-man ps4 and is actually Sam Raimi
spider-man but nonetheless it's a
picture of spider-man and it says wanted
on it just like he is after spider-man
far from home so this movie Morbius
takes place inside of the MCU they even
have actual characters from the MCU in
the movie and not to mention Jay jonah
Jameson is said to reprise his role as
well and we saw him at the end of
spider-man far from home so this movie
is really going to take place inside of
two different universes it's going to be
in the Sony verse but it's also going to
be a part of the MCU and I'm all for
that because this trailer actually looks
really really good let me know what you
thought about this trailer and let me
know what you think about the spider-man
references and appearances let me know
what you thought about this trailer in
the comics down below do you think Jared
Leto is going to crush this and do you
think it's going to be a good movie
don't forget to leave a like and
subscribe when notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Morbius spider-man and the
MCU and also so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 and picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff